you know I didn't set out to be a
parenting expert in fact I'm not very
interested in parenting per se it's just
that there's a certain style of
parenting these days that is kind of
messing up kids impeding their chances
to develop into their selves there's a
certain style of parenting these days
that's getting in the way I guess what
I'm saying is we spend a lot of time
being very concerned about parents who
aren't involved enough in the lives of
their kids and their education or their
upbringing and rightly so but at the
other end of the spectrum there's a lot
of harm going on there as well where
parents feel a kid can't be successful
unless the parent is protecting and
preventing at every turn and hovering
over every happening and micromanaging
every moment and steering their kid
towards some small subset of colleges
and careers
when we raise kids this way and I'll say
we because lord knows in raising my two
teenagers I've had these tendencies
myself our kids end up leading a kind of
checklist a childhood and here's what
the checklist did childhood looks like
we keep them safe and sound and fed and
watered and then we want to be sure they
go to the right schools but not just
that that they're in the right classes
at the right schools they get the right
grades in the right classes in the right
schools but not just the graves the
scores and not just the grades of scores
but the accolades and the awards and the
sports and the activities and the
leadership we tell our kids don't just
join a club start a club because
colleges want to see that and check the
box for community service I mean show
the college's you care about others
and all of this is done to some hope for
degree of perfection we expect our kids
to perform at a level of perfection we
were never asked to perform at ourselves
and so because so much is required we
think well then of course we parents
have to argue with every teacher and
principal and coach and referee and act
like our kids concierge and personal
Handler and
secretary and then with our kids our
precious kids we spend so much time
nudging cajoling hinting helping
haggling nagging as the case may be to
be sure they're not screwing up not
closing doors not ruining their future
some hoped for admission to a tiny
handful of colleges that deny almost
every applicant and
here's what it feels like to be a kid in
this check listed childhood first of all
there's no time for free play there's no
room in the afternoons because
everything has to be enriching we think
it's as if every piece of homework every
quiz every activity is a make-or-break
moment for this future we have in mind
for them and we absolve them of helping
out around the house and we even absolve
them of getting enough sleep as long as
they're checking off the items on their
checklist and in a checklist its
childhood we say we just want them to be
happy but when they come home from
school what we ask about all too often
first is their homework and their grades
and they see in our faces that our
approval that our love that their very
worth comes from A's and then we walk
alongside them and offer cluckin praise
like a trainer at the Westminster Dog
Show
coaxing them to just jump a little
higher and soar a little farther day
after day after day and when they get to
high school they don't say well what
might I be interested in studying or
doing as an activity they go to
counselors and they say what do I need
to do to get into the right College and
then when the grades start to roll in in
high school and they're getting some B's
or god forbid some C's they frantically
text their friends and say has anyone
ever gotten into the right college with
these grades and our kids regardless of
where they end up at the end of high
school
they're breathless
they're brittle they're a little burned
out they're a little old before their
time wishing the grown-ups in their
lives had said what you've done is
enough this effort you've put forth and
childhood is enough and they're
withering now under high rates of
anxiety and depression and some of them
are wondering will this life ever turn
out to have been worth it
well we parents we parents are pretty
sure it's all worth it we seem to behave
it's like we literally think they will
have no future if they don't get into
one of these tiny set of colleges or
careers we have in mind for them or
maybe
maybe we're just afraid they won't have
a future we can brag about to our
friends and with stickers on the backs
of our cars
yeah
but if you look at what we've done if
you have the courage to really look at
it you'll see that not only do our kids
think their worth comes from grades and
scores but that when we live right up
inside their precious developing minds
all the time like our very own version
of the movie Being John Malkovich we
send our children the message hey kid I
don't think you can actually achieve any
of this without me and so with our over
help our over protection over direction
and hand-holding we deprive our kids of
the chance to build self-efficacy which
is a really fundamental tenant of the
human psyche far more important than
that self-esteem they get every time we
have applaud
self-efficacy is built when one sees
that one's own actions lead to outcomes
not there you know
not one's parents actions on one's
behalf but when one's own actions lead
to outcome so simply put if our children
are to develop self-efficacy and they
must then they have to do a whole lot
more of the thinking planning deciding
doing hoping coping trial-and-error
dreaming and experiencing of life for
themselves
now am I saying every kid is hardworking
and motivated and doesn't need a parents
involvement or interest in their lives
and we should just back off and let go
hell no that
is not what I'm saying what I'm saying
is when we treat grades and scores and
accolades and awards as the purpose of
childhood all in furtherance of some
hope for admission to a tiny number of
colleges or entrance to a small number
of careers that that's too narrow a
definition of success for our kids and
even though we might help them achieve
some short-term wins by over helping
like they get a better grade if we help
with do their homework they might end up
with a longer childhood resume when we
help what I'm saying is is that all of
this comes at a long-term cost to their
sense of self what I'm saying is we
should be less concerned with a specific
set of colleges they might be able to
apply to or might get into and far more
concerned that they have the habits the
mindset the skillset the wellness to be
successful wherever they go what I'm
saying is our kids need us to be a
little less obsessed with grades and
scores and a whole lot more interested
in childhood providing a foundation for
their success built on things like love
and
chores
did I just say chores did I just say
chores I really did
but really here's why
the longest longitudinal study of humans
ever conducted it's called the Harvard
grant study it found that professional
success in life which is what we want
for our kids that professional success
in life comes from having done chores as
a kid and the earlier you started the
better that or roll up your sleeves and
pitch in mindset a mindset that says
there's some unpleasant work someone's
got to do it it might as well be me a
mindset that says I will contribute my
effort to the betterment of the whole
that that's what gets you ahead in the
workplace now we all know this you know
this
we all know this and yet in the Czech
listed childhood we absolve our kids of
doing the work of chores around the
house and then they end up as young
adults in the workplace still waiting
for a checklist but it doesn't exist and
more importantly lacking the impulse the
instinct to roll up their sleeves and
pitch in and look around and wonder how
can I be useful to my colleagues how can
I anticipate a few steps ahead to what
my boss might need a
second very important finding from the
Harvard grant study
said that happiness in life
comes from love not love of work love of
humans our spouse our partner our
friends our family so childhood needs to
teach our kids how to love and they
can't love others if they don't first
love themselves and they won't love
themselves if we can't offer them
unconditional love
right
and so
instead of being obsessed with grades
and scores when they come home when our
precious offspring come home from school
or we come home from work we need to
close our technology put away our phones
and look them in the eye and let them
see the joy that fills our faces when we
see our child for the first time in a
few hours and then we have to say how
was your day
what did you like about today and when
your teenage daughter says lunch
like-minded and I want to hear about the
math test not lunch you have to still
take an interest in lunch you got to say
what was great about lunch today they
need to know they matter to us as humans
not because of their GPA
alright so you're thinking tours and
love that sounds all well and good but
give me a break the colleges want to see
top scores and grades and accolades and
awards and I'm going to tell you sorta
the very biggest brand name schools are
asking that of our young adults but
here's the good news
contrary to what the college rankings
racket would have us believe
you don't have to go to one of the
biggest brand-name schools to be happy
and successful in life happy and
successful people went to a state school
went to a small college no one has heard
of went to Community College went to a
college over here
the evidence is in this room is in our
communities that this is the truth and
if we could widen our blinders and be
willing to look at a few more colleges
maybe remove our own egos from the
equation we could accept and embrace
this truth and then realize it is hardly
the end of the world if our kids don't
go to one of those big brand-name
schools and
more importantly if their childhood has
not been lived according to a tyrannical
checklist then when they get to college
whichever one it is well they'll have
gone there on their own volition
fueled by their own desire
capable and ready to thrive there I
have to admit something to you I've got
two kids I mentioned Sawyer and Avery
they're teenagers and once upon a time I
think I was treating my Sawyer and Avery
like little bonsai trees
that I was going to carefully clip and
prune and shape into some perfect form
of a human that might just be perfect
enough to warrant them admission to one
of the most highly selective colleges
but I've come to realize after working
with thousands of other people's kids
[Laughter]
and raising two kids of my own
my kids aren't bonsai trees
they're wildflowers of an unknown genus
and species and
it's my job to provide a nourishing
environment to strengthen them through
chores and to love them so they can love
others and receive love and the college
the major the career that's up to them
my job is not to make them become what I
would have them become but to support
them in becoming their glorious selves
thank you